Elvis Elvis became a legend in his
lifetime can the rcz r follow that feat
wonders our car tester eNOS with an
output of 199 kilowatts this is the most
powerful production model Puzo ever
built the RCZ was launched back in 2010
it was followed by the performance or
added our addition in the fall of 2013
among the engine special features is the
twin-scroll turbocharger it translates
into a faster throttle response and
sumptuous acceleration even at low revs
it takes the RCZ R 5.9 seconds to make
it from 0 to 100 km/h top speed is
limited to 250 km/h
so my mom's fun Eva's feels the awesome
force behind the ancient as soon as she
starts off at just 1900 rpms it's
already delivering 330 newton meters of
torque down country roads it's a smooth
mover around bends with great steering
but it's on the autobahn that this baby
really lets rip even in 6th gear it
accelerates with ease at high speed
about a month the steering is nice and
tight report zenus with good feedback
even at high speeds you're comfortably
in control although the rcz r was
designed with sporty rides in mind it's
a perfectly relaxed and comfortable set
of wheels for everyday use as well the
car takes note of a driver's rev range
and use of the accelerator and then
adapts to that style
I'm blinkin in books demons can see the
flared wheel arches out her window that
reinforces the impression of power in
this car
the body of the our edition was lowered
by 10 millimeters and the tighter sports
tuned suspension also means it really
hugs the road
Oh
unlike the regular rcz the r version has
a fixed rear spoiler that helps
stabilize the handling at high speeds
the visual highlight at the back is the
gentle double bubble roof and rear
windshield
by these mouths those exciting contours
might have you thinking this is a
mid-engine sports car sassiness but the
RCZ R has the engine up front and has
front-wheel drive the advantage here is
having a massive trunk which is very
practical of course and close boom
tamiya talk
the RCZ R is powered by a turbocharged
1.6 liter four-cylinder engine which
puts out a fantastic sound both inside
and out I'm in love the interior is a
successful bridging of classic and
modern concludes eNOS and when you don't
need the display you can just flip it
down giving you an even better view of
the road ahead the our designation
applies just as much to the interior
with sporty bucket seats red stitching
highlighting and sophisticated materials
all around
come on I'm absolutely penis now returns
to her initial question whether rcz r
has what it takes to become a legend in
other words unique and unforgettable the
RCZ ours power and performance are
certainly memorable and its unique to
that wave in the roof and glass makes it
truly unforgettable